alors ça est ce que je fais il faut s
que je kiffe pas kelly je vais dire que
steam qu'ailier alors je ne connais pas
personnellement cette dame nice et ses
opinions donc c'est hors de ce que je
vais dire là mais ça revient au même que
lorsqu'on dit quelle conne et qu'on est
filmée à notre insu auquel devait se
préparer mais c'était un mec de lui dire
là tu vas être à l'antenne après c'est
sa personne elle elle fume dans la vie
est belle elle fume avant l'antenne et
on va pas se mentir il ya des gens qui
fument dans leur bureau et il ya des
gens qui savent mesurer les noms et
dates et on va voir ça répond non mais
qu'elle fume ça ne sait pas trop quel
film qui me dérange on se souvient de
l'image à l'époque de jacques chirac
avec simone veil fumée tout s'efface les
épaules ça laissait voir s'ils ont
changé
vous avez dit jacques chirac et qui vont
là bas voilà le dise n'importe quoi la
croix l'histoire on à l'américaine ici
oui et en fait les époques ont changé
sauf que là maintenant moi ce qui me
dérange c'est qui c'est toujours pareil
avec les politiques c'est vous vous avez
le droit vous êtes au dessus des lois et
nous les français on doit se taire on
doit pas le faire c'est ça certains
lieux publics c'est la loi evin ça t'as
pas le droit sûr mais dans un lieu
public un drapeau de la france
et là tu fumes c'est toujours nous les
politiques on est au dessus on est
mortel vous taisez vous c'est ça qui me
dérange pas ça qui dérange bien oui oui
valérie wyss et il a raison ce alors
c'est pas de bol pour elle parce
qu'effectivement c'est à l'insu de son
plein gré comme dirait l'autre on est en
l'occurrence effectivement et ça ça
donne une image assez désastreuse de jeu
je vous dis de faire des choses et moi
j'en fais d'autres et pour les
politiques c'est désastreux ce genre de
communication presse encore un couac de
communication
mais ce désastre pour eux d'un couac ce
à quoi jean michel maire oui bah moi je
veux j'ai envie de regarder le côté
positif parce qu'évidemment le tabac
c'est nocif ida m'en fous pas fumer
évidemment c'est interdit voilà mais on
a tellement reproché aux hommes
politiques d'être d'être des des gens
qui qui qui sont faux voilà qui sont qui
sont ici roulant des tirs ne sont pas
des robots des gens qui sont la
communication toujours tout est préparé
l'envoi quelqu'un dans sa vraie nature
voilà qui ne triche pas oui mais je ne
sais pas bien mais au moins pour une
fois elle est telle qu'elle est telle
que les hommes politiques de prêts sont
un phénomène actuel même s'il faut
serrer qu'elle tombe à l'histoire c'est
sa vraie nature c'est vrai je tenais ma
vraie nature moi j'aime bien si quand
y'a personne sur la route à deux heures
du matin avec un rôle à 180 c ma vraie
nature
sauf que c'est la loi baptisée centre
est donc la loi c 130